by around three percent
um we've reduced that a little bit
because we don't think it's as given
effect on productivity as we thought but
there's clearly been a big effect on
labor Supply here
um some of it may be attributed to
difficulties in the Health Service I
mean there
is question I think it probably is too
soon to draw a definitive conclusions
about why we've seen such a big increase
in the activity relative to other
countries because other countries Health
Services were also disruptive
um by the pandemic and to some extent uh
still are so I don't think you can draw
any immediately direct conclusions at
the moment but people are looking into
this had something weird they continue
to look at in the course of our work is
trying to understand what other drivers
of this rather unusual big Rising
inactivity that we've seen here in the
UK but
um you have seen some some big scars
from the pandemic itself as well as as
David was saying from from the right
just the productivity of businesses
which are particularly those which are
energy it tends to be just raising their
unit cost
and so one of the key drivers in our
long-term productivity forecast is not
so much what's happening Energy prices
now but where the markets expect Energy
prices to end up in the middle of the
decade you know once we see that once we
see some kind of resolution to the
European energy crisis whether we find
alternative sources of energy on the
renewable side or whether we find new
ways of bringing gas into our gas hungry
economy no matter what price will they
take energy by the time below that at
the moment markers still think that that
price of energy is going to be twice
what it was before the pandemic and that
means long-term Stars
thanks Richard
another question in the room
thank you David Robertson market news
and you've again forecast that the
saving ratio declined strong and Sierra
which is the view shared and Bank of
England North widely elsewhere
some people say recent date and the way
against that if you look at bank
deposits and others
it makes quite a big difference to your
forecast trying to explain why he is
still holding to that forecast and what
difference it makes if it were not about
um it's true we have a lower savings
rate forecast and many other certainly
in the bank and have had
um I'm not sure where they're currently
doing it or not
um
I think maybe you're going to ruin it
unless but early maybe when I was
probably mentioned one thing that I
think is relevant here which is that a
zero savings rate when you Define
savings as excluding contributions where
people don't have much discretion
sounds unusual the historically ignored
I think I might be saying that for much
as a period between about 2000 up to the
financial crisis almost the first decade
of this century
on that measure anyway the household
symptoms during the UK fluctuated around
zero it wasn't much above that
so it wouldn't be that unusual to have a
savings rate that low and I think there
were some
pretty obvious reason why you might
expect the savings rate to be low
um the hit terminal disposable income is
very material over a couple of years
something like six percent of people's
disposable income
is a temporary hit because we've got the
place of gas coming down it doesn't get
back to where it was before but it does
fall off as you move through this year
and go into the
um sort of medium term
s of view it as a big but to some extent
temporary reduction it's natural enough
that those that can smooth a bit the
impact but to some extent temporary or
consumption do so so that really is the
logic Behind These
the lowest savings rate that that than
others which I
uh you know we take it we can still a
plausible and Central
forecast
because it's also the case that with
inflation at least at the moment we can
still become that job at least at the
moment
um pretty close to 10 even though the
interest rate people are getting all
those deposits maybe two two and a half
percent that's a minus eight percent
minus seven minus eight percent
there's a whole lot of incentive certain
to save in the form of
deposits with the banking system that
are paying rates that are unliking to be
quite close to bank
thanks David
thank you David BBC News
um you've broken out uh how the feasible
thresholds could impact the number of
taxpayers uh so you could create 3.2
million new taxpayers does that figure
just look at the thresholds and the
current levels of deployment or have you
taken into account your forecast for
employment growth and also what will
that figure of look like if we haven't
seen the CPI out of Trinity can ask
online that's very similar and I'm
probably going to turn to Andy this is I
think quite a direct question how many
more people will be put into operative
income tax at the end of your forecast
due to the amount of phrases
okay let's let's take those again so
um these threshold freezes in the uh in
the income tax National Insurance is the
running for five years are generating
very powerful physical
more people into the tax system
the the 3.2 million additional taxpayers
is consistent with our final forecast
for includes
includes the growth that they exist
seed by inflation numbers
the uh the effect of changes to our
forecast for CPI inflation obviously
looking very small since last November I
think last November is the numbers
they just they
made the answer it's very similar
um in terms of a higher rate in the top
rate so because the threshold between
the higher and the top rate is chair
managed
the additional rate we expect 350 000
more people to pay additional rates at
the end of the forecast than would it be
in the case without the threshold being
reduced and we expect just over 2
million more people to be paying a
higher rate than would it be in the case
without the threshold fees is having the
movement
but because the additional rate of
thresholders come down that means some
people who were previously higher rate
taxpayers at the top of that you're not
paying attention so if you take those
two groups together that's two and a
half
um next question
[Music]
um
probably for Richard David your initial
the super deduction impact was a 10
boost to investment
which he brought down to five percent
how do you see the risks to your three
percent impact of the new uh full
exposing measure
especially considering the higher cost
of investing currently
the risks are clearly there and it is
the case that this has been the first
time we've seen uh Capital allowances
being given in the corporation tax
system to try and stimulate investment
last time around with a super deduction
which is actually more generous it was
130 of tax rate you're getting more back
to the tax when you were investing
meant we initially thought that would
that would raise investment by around 10
um we knocked back down to five percent
in based on our latest estimates I think
it's important to bear in mind that we
have had an energy crisis in the
meantime
um that clearly both reduces the return
that you might get under investment what
we've also see more recently as a rise
interest rates which raises the cost of
financing that investment so that was a
policy operating in a relatively
volunteer and unstable environment
um this policy is less generous in the
sense there's only 100 Capital
allowances for investment so we so we've
brought down our experience impact
partly because it's less generous
um down just adding three percent to
investment per year but also learning
from learning lessons from the first
outing to this policy a few years ago in
the formula super deduction so it makes
it makes a material difference to
investment Embroidery in the three years
in which it's in place but it's
important also to mention that because
it's a temporary policy is a temporary
impact on investments so it has an
impact on investment up until 2036 then
when it expires investment without
forecast falls back in the final two
years because the additional generosity
for investment Falls away and
corporations in the space
um the full 25 CT rate
um on all of their profits and as a
result in cumulative terms over the
forecast period between 2022 and the end
of the forecast the level of investment
has really broadly unchanged
thanks Richard uh the next question is
from Sue Chan at the telegraph uh how
much of the rise in the tax burden is
due to physical growth given your
assumption that the recent stroking
receipts will continue is it more
powerful in this forecast and also why
have you revised up forecasts for
capital gains so much
okay so
um the first question is a fiscal drag
um it's it's not possible to split this
out precisely but the threshold for
these measures that we're just
discussing are fiscal drag on
turbochargers and they raise about one
percent of GDP
uh by the end of the forecast we have a
tax to the GDP ratio that between 2019
and 20
before the pandemic at the end of our
forecast Rises by almost five percentage
um normal fiscal drag would get you
about one percent of GDP and these
measures add another one so in very
broad terms
half the other thing is that raised the
taxidency ratio significantly there are
of course the corporation tax rise that
takes place next April
now in terms of the specific question on
capital gains tax
um that's quite a simple answer in the
capital gains tax uh is paid once a year
in January and the uh the amount that
was the amount that arrived this January
significantly higher than our previous
forecast
and it's a tax that has been and we
forecast to grow quite quickly because
gains the tax base typically buys much
faster than the asset prices on which
they are they are made
the next question is from Aleister
McQueen bit of Aviva who says the obr
forecasts closed on the 9th of March
referring to when we took Market
determinants for our final forecast uh
before the collapse of Silicon Valley
Bank
guilt yields have since born and
significantly what are the implications
of this form for the OVR forecasts which
do you want to start on that one yeah so
um
have just been very volatile
really over the course of the last three
months and including in recent weeks
um broadly speaking of wellness and
rise or calling Bill yields changes
borrowing by about 20 billion pounds in
the final year of our forecast so that's
more than the six and a half billion
pounds of this
against his physical Target in the final
year
um we'd seen guilty of themselves Jump
Around by about half a percent so about
half of that 20 billion pounds about 10
billion pounds up or down looked at in
isolation I think it's important though
to stress that you can't really just
view these things in isolation uh
interest rates can jump around for a
number of different reasons it could be
an expectation of poor inflation it
could be an expectation of more real
growth or it could be an addition of
lower inflation and lower and lower rate
size of the economy which matters to
things like this or drag and the amount
of tax receipts
seen in isolation roughly speaking one
percent either way our interest rate is
about 30 billion pounds
obviously so far as interest rates going
up and then coming back down by
um
is actually back back when we uh we
envisioned the forecast pretty much
having having gone up quite a lot until
a few days ago and then come down really
rather sharply
um it's actually quite my chance
in terms of the year old government
problems they're now
on the whole trivia different from the
Assumption we made in the forecast
looking centered so weeks ago although
until a couple of days ago we were we
were thinking what the impact might be
of yours being higher for the moment
that that's a bit of a non-question yes
uh do you want to be in the room if you
want to dive in you do get um the right
to ask multiple questions for having
joined us in person but Meanwhile we're
going to take a question from Anne Isaac
the guardian
uh this might be one for you initially
what risk is there to your forecasts if
the government does not clear the NHS
backlog in line with its Ambitions can
that be Quantified
um yeah so I think clearly there are
risks to both our forecasts by the labor
market and our forecast today spending
on various parts of the welfare system
that are likely to be linked to the NHS
backlog we have not Quantified those
links either on the economy or the
fiscal side
but
the things that uh the things that one
would like to know more about are
the age composition of the NHS backlogs
I think uh I think
many if not most are above working age
so you might think that the implications
are greater for some of the
fiscal benefit side of our forecasting
rather than the big Market activity side
and then obviously you would like to
link whether people who have been on the
waiting list for a long time are
actually those who are falling out of
the main market for a ill health reasons
or
arriving on the benefit laws which have
been rising very sharply so I think
it seems logical that that risk that if
the NHS backlog were to remain higher
for longer that those risks would be
able to quantify I think we'd like
um
a couple of questions I think on the
quite broad questions are the risks
around the forecast now so my husky
start Richard
um one you say a few Duty freeze could
have four billions borrowings if Capital
allowances where it said that they could
add 10 million if defense spending was
raised to 2.5 percent GDP it could add
15 billion does that mean that
realistically the transness likely or
state of political Ambitions will leave
him missing his borrowing a debt Targets
this question around the kind of
um policy
forecast and then a different question
says how do you expect public debt
levels
um to go if you're if GDP broken
interest rates do not meet your
forecasts and how does the government
intend to sustain debt levels if uh
those those forecasts are not met so I
think that's kind of one question about
the economy we're still forecasted one
question about some of the policy works
so on the policy questions it is the
case that there are certain policy
additions booked around making the
investment allowances determinants as
well as around defense spending
um which are not in our forecast because
they're not their Ambitions they're not
stated policies it's long been the case
that hanging over and then there's
obviously feel whatever the chance
decides to do about fuels usually
years it's always been the case
that these Ambitions have kind of hung
over our forecasts as risks people may
remember that the previous prime
minister talked about getting
defensively up to three percent of GDP
the current one is talking back to the
other two and a half
um these Ambitions are always there for
the moment their caveaters will do it
when we when we can afford it
um and therefore we don't assume that
it's going to happen now and probably
into our forecast because it's clearly
not happening
um but we would do where the government
to make make that payment S I think the
second thing to say about policy
Ambitions is that there are different
ways of meeting they don't necessarily
need to act boring if if they are
re-prioritized within the overall
spending on bullets and offset other
parts of content spending so
um we also don't know whether this
couldn't is to spend more money on
defense is going to mean additional
boring over the next five years or it
just means they're going to spend less
on health education and other
departments um in order to accommodate
that ambition so that's that's the
reason why we are
question
yes well at the end of the forecast
Horizon on our Central forecast over the
debt to GDP ratio is not much different
from 100 and it's a bit it's a bit less
than that so you have a three trillion
about 3 000.
billion having a problem
um and
so that the mouse is nice because you
know the debt is about the same order of
magnitude so GDP level or one percent
lower and you want to defeat the GBP
ratio where it was you need 30 billion
pounds off the stock of debt and if you
had to do all that at the last minute
that's 30 billion pounds of spending on
on taxation that's certainly a big
number which is partially the reason for
our assessment of the probability
that the government will provide to me
is or Headroom actually hits its Target
is a bit better than 50 but it is a lot
better than 50
because one percent of GDP as a forecast
five years down the road either way
either on the good side on the bus side
um is not an extraordinarily large hit
but I mean when we were in 2020 the
level of GDP total or 10 they're they're
about pandemic so you know a one percent
deviation from the level of GDP five
years down the road would not be a
particularly large forecasting error I'm
ashamed to say
um
so
and of course tax revenue and spending
is sensitive to GDP it's also sensitive
to inflation and the cost of government
debt is highly sensitive to fluctuations
in interest rates and more sensitive to
short-term insurance now that
historically it's dealing because so
much more of the debt effectively in
this short term so there are plenty of
things that could happen on the good
Federal on the bad side that could take
the amount of Headroom well above the
six and a half billion or or
inter-negative territory
um of course the government's got lots
of leaders to move between now and then
if things start to move in certain
direction so I don't want to leave
people with the impression that we think
the chances of the government would hit
the target or or very low because they
can do things about yourself
um
but
even relatively small economic jobs can
have a pretty big impact on the physical
situation and the stock of debt which of
course we've seen over the last uh four
or five years and spectacularly over the
last 50 years
thanks uh very much David we got time
for a few more questions
um we've got plenty online
um our people out in the room uh quite a
specific question on the listing to pay
if I come to your little Mandy do fiscal
forecast stability in public sector pay
at three percent for the next year
next year our our fiscal forecasts are
provisioned on
sending in the determinants assessments
less so specifically on pay Awards
so on but I think it would be fair to
say that yes our forecast is still
consistent with the uh the maintenance
of resource spending that were allocated
environments in spending reviews and
that I think have been consistently with
three or three and a half percent is a
an amount that can be paid now the
government's policy is essentially to
wait for the pay review bodies to report
for making decisions on pay Awards in
your head so in a sense we are
conditioned on policy as it stands
awaiting news should be different
forecast
thank you and they um
have a question related to brexit now
can you say roughly how much of the 340
billion pound shortfall in business
investment since 2016 you attribute to
brexit which will David will be on that
one um I don't think it's possible to
attribute because the economy's been
faced by so many surprises over the last
several years I don't think it's
possible to ascribe particular shots to
investment to particular events um we
you know we've had the EU referendum and
we haven't found out about the energy
crisis all these things have created an
atmosphere of uncertainty about Prospect
and how we do business both within the
UK and also with our trade department so
I don't think it's I I don't think
anyone can actually put a number on what
has been the brexit effect on
investments versus the effect of the
pandemic versus the energy crisis
um it's certainly the case that
investment
um has not has not grown in real service
since 2016. I've been actually fell
during the pandemic it's now I've only
just recovered
um to those 2016 levels um and it's it
was down about 16 on the even the
pandemic and now
um it's down by about 30 compared to
what we forecast the level of investment
to be before um
uh the EU referendum 2016
um you can't describe all of that to
brexit um we've had a pandemic had an
energy crisis
um and I think but you can't respond
back to the fact that we've had an
uncertain environment for investment
here in the UK
um uh then then we have a little
forecasting um backing
thank you
cool
let's follow up on that one I believe
the bank has a slightly lower figure of
sort of brexit impact of the supply side
but beliefs that it's come through more
quickly than expected I'm just wondering
where you stand on the timing of your
thoughts and hit
there are three different assumptions
that go into what we assume about the
economic impact of the concert from the
EU on the forecast one is on one is on
trade the secondary investments in the
third is on migration
on on an investment I talked about on
trade I hope you say that what we've
seen so far is more or less consistent
with our assumption that over time over
a period of about 15 years we see the
trade intensity of the UK economy sort
of a measure of the openness of the UK
um Fall by about 15 over that period
compared to what we thought was going to
happen
um will be to remain the meeting you if
you look at what's happened to trade
volumes here compared to trade volumes
elsewhere in the world uh you know UK
trade volumes now are about three
percent below where they were in 2019 in
other countries despite the pandemic
trade volumes are about five and a half
percent above where they were in 2019 so
um I describe that was broadly
consistent with getting to that 15
number over a period I wouldn't say they
were necessarily a head or behind
um in terms of hitting that long run
Target the thing that has surprised us
now
has been a level of migration since we
left the EU in that we were initially
thinking that the post-gregate migration
regime
um would emit around 129 000 net buyers
into the UK
um in steady state as a result of its
operation
um what we've seen as much higher levels
of migration
um since uh since 2020 uh the latest
podcast numbers were around 500 000
migrants now some of that may have been
temporary we took it a lot of a lot of
refugees in Ukraine we took in people
from Hong Kong and other places but we
we had over time revised up our estimate
but we think net wireless is going to be
from 129 000 to Our Last Broadcast 205
000 and then in this forecast 245 000
is what we expect to be the consequence
of the operational residue regime so
they then sort of
two hits which we think are broadly
consistent with what we thought we made
it out for
trade we've been surprised on the upside
in terms of levels of migration those
people some of those people do join the
workforce and they support output
um
thanks Richard I think we've got time
for one more question and it's quite
broad one to conclude on
um so
um don't you think you're forecast are
overly optimistic how does the
government intend to pay for this new
spending without increasing taxes in the
longer term you can take that question
and add any final words here it's
sure and so we always compare our
forecasts with those of other other
independent forecasters out there I mean
you can see on the chart 2.23
um which is actually the last chart for
the economy chapter
um you know you want to give us how our
forecast Compares it is it is the case
um that our forecast is
um just under one percent more
optimistic about the growth Outlook than
the average
um that does reflect as David was saying
a number of factors one is the fact that
you know ours is the most recent
forecast as of today there'll be more
after this but the picture on energy
crisis has been improving over time and
it's been also the case that everyone
loves broadcasts to be improving as it
looks like Energy prices are coming down
not just in the theater and medium term
so the time it reflects the fact that
the news has been getting better about
the UK economy over time it also
reflects uh to some extent uh the impact
of the policy measures announced just
today on the labor Supply as well as in
the near term the pulse moves that
stimulate investment
um so that's another reason why we're a
bit above other forecasters and finally
you know this news on migration and what
it means for the performance of the
population and the labor force
environment foreign
which is that we are seeing interest
rates you know triple in the course of a
year we're seeing Energy prices about
Seven Falls
um and then come back by half and
half from in the course of the year
um these are huge changes which have
very big Macross effects because
immediately and about economic and
fiscal prospects in five years time and
so one of the things which we always
emphasize and it's good that we've
talked in this session about risks and
shocks is the fact that no Central
forecast
um you know survives six months uh that
you know possibly six days in an economy
like the uks at the moment given all the
events going on here and going on the
world these things are always a snapshot
of the world as we understand today but
the world is changing constantly
um and forecasters are constantly having
a key Pace with big shots managing
prices big shots of interest rates
um there's been also lots of news today
about the storyline financial markets
that will mean that our next forecast
will also look different from this
forecast because it will reflect how we
see the world and the old film rather
balancing the world
as I said so we've got time for this
afternoon so apologies to the key
questions online that we didn't get to
and I'll just wrap up by saying thank
you very much for joining us today and
we look forward to seeing you at our
next event in the summer
thank you